diese skandal vor gericht in
braunschweig startet ein musterverfahren
gegen volkswagen stellvertretend für
rund 470.000 dieselfahrer auf einen
blick mit dem sogenannten three score
sollen verbraucher künftig ungesunde
lebensmittel schneller erkennen
kräftiger wind starker regen ein
sturmtief wütet in norddeutschland und
sorgt für chaos bei der bahn
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers einen schönen guten
abend in allen heute um 7 der kompakten
überblick über ihren nachrichten tag
sport natürlich auch dabei nachher mit
ruedi zahner hallo guten habt das erste
große gerichtsverfahren hat heute
begonnen um ein großes streitthema fast
eine halbe million dieselfahrer
versuchen vor gericht ihre chancen zu
erhöhen dass sie doch eine entschädigung
von volkswagen bekommen im abgas skandal
solche musterklagen sind in deutschland
noch ein ziemlich neues instrument gegen
volkswagen klagen die
verbraucherzentrale und der adac
stellvertretend für rund 470.000
dieselfahrer die sich in ein klage
register eingetragen haben für sie
bleibt der prozess kostenlos vor gericht
geht es allein um die frage hat
volkswagen betrogen oder nicht sagt das
gericht ja dann können die betroffenen
in einzel prozessen auf schadensersatz
klagen
elisabeth schmidt das gepäck der anwälte
sagt alles hier rollt ein mammutprozess
an das oberlandesgericht braunschweig
muss über fünf dutzend anträge
entscheiden bei denen es im kern immer
darum geht muss volkswagen kunden
entschädigen die vom diesen skandal
betroffen sind
am ende des ersten verhandlungstages
wollen beide parteien den etappensieg
für sich verbuchen
zur frage der zulässigkeit der anträge
hat der senat heute sich dahingegen
positioniert dass die wesentlichen
anträge der kläger nämlich die die auf
feststellung des schadens an
ersatzanspruch dem grunde nach
unzulässig sein dürften
doch damit sei nur die maximalforderung
vom tisch argumentieren die kläger
jetzt gehe es darum forderungen und
ansprüche genauer zu definieren
wir haben heute darüber gefreut dass der
senat auf jeden fall gesagt hat dass
ernsthaft in betracht zu ziehen ist das
ein anspruch aus vorsätzlich
sittenwidriger schädigung in betracht
kommt also schadenersatz zu leisten sein
wird die richter deuteten aber auch an
bei einem möglichen schadenersatz würden
die gefahrenen kilometer der diesel
kunden berücksichtigt und verrechnet
heißt je länger der prozess dauert desto
weniger schadenersatz könnte für
betroffene autofahrer wie heinrichs
dollar herausspringen
ihm geht es bei der muster
feststellungsklage aber auch ums prinzip
wir haben uns hinters licht geführt die
haben die abstand einrichtung eingebaut
und suggeriert dafür ein sauberes auto
haben gehofft dass diese kunden wie er
vor gericht recht bekommen
doch selbst dann steht fest geld wird
nach dem musterprozess erstmal nicht
fließen jeder diese kunde müsste dann
seinen schadenersatzanspruch in einzel
prozessen klären lassen
man hofft durch den entscheid durch dem
muster entscheid dass der das urteil in
dem musterverfahren dass der druck auf
die so groß ist dass insgesamt ein
überzeugendes vergleichsangebot erfolgt
volkswagen hält vergleichsverhandlungen
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt allerdings für
verfrüht mitte november wird in
braunschweig weiter verhandelt
rechtsexperten gehen davon aus dass der
musterprozess vor dem bundesgerichtshof
landen wird und bis zu vier jahre dauern
kann
und jetzt in der sendung der blick auf
zwei wichtige statistiken erstmal die
preisentwicklung im september sind die
preise in deutschland nur langsam
gestiegen die inflationsrate liegt bei
1,2 prozent gegenüber 1,4 im august
energie und nahrungsmittel wurden kaum
teurer überdurchschnittlich angestiegen
sind dagegen die mieten und dann der
arbeitsmarkt dort ist die zahl der
arbeitslosen gesunken auf den
niedrigsten stand seit der
wiedervereinigung nach angaben der
bundesagentur für arbeit waren zwei
millionen 234.000 menschen ohne
beschäftigung das sind 85.000 weniger
als im august die arbeitslosenquote sank
auf 4,9 prozent im vergleich zum
september 2018 ist die zahl der menschen
ohne job um 22.000 zurückgegangen viele
supermarkt kunden kennen dass der griff
ins regal das produkt schön verpackt
aber die zutatenliste ist im
kleingedruckten kaum zu erkennen damit
soll jetzt schluss sein eine
nährwertampel vom grünen a bis zum roten
g soll verbrauchern künftig beim einkauf
helfen
die zuständige ministerin hat sie heute
vorgestellt patricia wiedemeier
ernährungsministerin klöckner
präsentierte das ergebnis einer
verbraucherbefragung über das neue
nährwert logo heute wie bei einer
preisverleihung dabei geht es lediglich
um ein neues freiwilliges zeichen für
lebensmittel der gewinner ist mit risco
erstens er ist auf den ersten blick
erfassbar
zweitens er ist leicht zu verstehen
drittens er nutzt die eingängige bereits
gelernte farbwelt einer ampel das kennen
wir zum beispiel auch bei elektrogeräten
in einer fünfstufigen skala von einem
grünen a für die günstigste bilanz bis
zu einem roten g für das ungesündesten
werden die lebensmittel beurteilt dabei
werden der gehalt an zucker fett und
salz aber auch empfehlenswerte
bestandteile wie ballaststoffe oder
proteine bewertet in frankreich gibt es
nur drei score bereits künftig wohl auch
bei uns zusätzlich zur bisherigen
nährwerttabelle verbraucherschützern
reicht das alleine jedoch nicht wir
brauchen weiterhin eine ambitionierte
reduktion strategie für weniger zucker
fett und salz in lebensmitteln oder wir
brauchen auch werbebeschränkungen für
lebensmittel mit kinder optik für die
hersteller ist die kennzeichnung mit
niedrig score jedoch freiwillig die
wirkung daher eher begrenzt nur eu
regeln können alle verpflichten für uns
als lebensmittelhandel ist es immer
wichtig dass wir alles tun um den
europäischen binnenmarkt so einfach wie
möglich zu gestalten und man sollte
überlegen ob man nicht künftig auf
europäischer ebene für alle eu staaten
gleich über eine arbeitete
nährwertkennzeichnung nachdenkt hätten
klöckner oder einer ihrer vorgänger sich
früher für niedrig score entschieden und
dafür in der eu gekämpft könnte eine
verbindliche eu regelung schon weiter
seien viele weitere fragen zum neuen
lebensmittel kennzeichen haben wir
online zusammengestellt und beantwortet
natürlich alles auf heute.de und jetzt
zu einem prozess den der
generalbundesanwalt als einen der
bedeutendsten im bereich rechts
terrorismus bezeichnet
in dresden stehen acht mutmaßliche
mitglieder der rechtsextremen zelle
revolution chemnitz vor gericht
gucken wir zurück chemnitz august
vergangenes jahr einen syrer ersticht
den deutschen daniel h danach ist die
situation aufgeheizt es gibt aufmärsche
und rassistische übergriffe in diesem
klima
die gruppe revolution chemnitz ausländer
angegriffen und den gewaltsamen umsturz
der demokratischen ordnung geplant haben
so steht es in der anklage vom beginn
des prozesses berichtet thomas bärsch
die vertreter der bundesanwaltschaft
gehen davon aus dass die acht
angeklagten die heute in dresden vor
ihren richter traten nicht mehr und
nicht weniger wollten als die
bundesrepublik verein zu fall zu bringen
das hatten sie über chat nachrichten
verabredet auch ein datum stand schon
fest
nach unseren ermittlungen hat diese
vereinigung vorgehabt den dritten
oktober 2018 in berlin als auftakt für
so einen gewaltsamen systemwechsel zu
nutzen und das auch mit schusswaffen
einsatz
wenige tage nach den chemnitzer randalen
im september 2008 eine bis dahin
unbekannte gruppe namens revolution
chemnitz streift als selbsternannte
bürgerwehr durch den stadtpark und
attackiert auch ausländer
auch diese aktion ist heute gegenstand
der anklage
zum zweiten wird den angeklagten
vorgeworfen am 14 september 2018 im
rahmen des so genannten probelauf schon
mal die aktionsfähigkeit der gruppe zu
testen
dabei ist es auch zu einer
körperverletzung gekommen das heißt im
weiteren sind einige der angeklagten
wegen schweren landfriedensbruch und
einer auch wegen gefährlicher
körperverletzung angeklagt verteidiger
hingegen beklagten heute dass es sich um
einen politisch motivierten prozess
handele
ein mandant stünde zb ganz allein wegen
drei chat-nachrichten nun als terrorist
vor gericht nicht alle verteidiger
schlossen sich dem vorwurf an aber
selbstverständlich hat dieser prozess
eine politische einer meinung komponente
und man muss eben darauf achten dass
alleine die politische gesinnung nicht
dazu führt jemanden als rechtsextremen
oder rechts terroristen zur verurteilung
zu bringen
für ein urteil wird sich das gericht bis
weit ins nächste jahr zeit nehmen im
falle von schuldsprüchen sieht das
gesetz bis zu zehn jahren haft vor
die künftige eu kommissionschef ursula
von der leyen hat ein personalproblem
ihre kommissars kandidaten aus ungarn
und rumänien sind dem rechtsausschuss
des eu-parlaments durchgefallen
der grund ihnen wird vorgeworfen in
dubiose finanzgeschäfte verwickelt zu
sein
jetzt bemüht sich von der leyen um
ersatzkandidaten ungarn reagierte
bereits und will einen ehemaligen eu
botschafter ins rennen schicken
die lage im flüchtlingslager von moria
auf der griechischen insel lesbos bleibt
angespannt gestern war dort ein feuer
ausgebrochen mindestens eine frau kam
ums leben
die behörden gehen davon aus dass auch
ihre beiden kinder in den flammen
starben
danach gab es gewaltsame proteste der
bewohner einige behinderten die
löscharbeiten
das lager ist mit tausenden flüchtlingen
völlig überfüllt hilfsorganisationen
berichten von katastrophalen zuständen
sie fordern dass maria evakuiert wird
frankreich hat heute abschied genommen
von seinem ehemaligen präsidenten bei
der trauerfeier für jacques chirac in
paris erwiesen ihm tausende franzosen
die letzte ehre
ebenso polit prominenz aus aller welt
von 1995 bis 2007 war chirac
staatspräsident vergangenen donnerstag
war er gestorben im alter von 86 jahren
nach deutschland das wetter wird
ungemütlicher und jetzt fehlt auch der
erste herbststurm über das land
sturmtief mortimer hat er sich schon am
wochenende angekündigt heute morgen dann
schwere sturmböen in norddeutschland und
später auch richtung osten
das traf vor allem mal wieder die
bahnfahrer der fernverkehr wurde
zwischendurch auf mehreren wichtigen
strecken eingestellt florian tkocz bange
blicke nach oben ein bild an vielen
bahnhöfen heute in deutschland etliche
verbindungen fallen aus viele wissen
nicht wann es für sie weitergeht
hab auch keine informationen jetzt
bekommen
wann und ob er überhaupt noch wert ist
klar wir haben alle irgendwo termine wir
wollen irgendwie alle ankommen aber ich
glaube gegen sturm kann man nichts
machen wir hängen erhalt fest ein
bisschen gestrandet noch schlimmer kommt
es für die die unterwegs stranden weil
auf halber strecke plötzlich schluss ist
bei wolfsburg prallt ein ece gegen einen
baum fahrt ändern
die 250 passagiere müssen zwei stunden
ausharren werden dann von einsatzkräften
befreit und zum nächsten bahnhof
gebracht mit voller wucht der sturm auch
über die lausitz hinweg auf einer brücke
erfasste er offenbar ein lkw und reißt
ihn in die tiefe
der fahrer kann leicht verletzt geborgen
werden tödlich dagegen endet ein unfall
in sachsen anhalt von wind und wetter
überrascht werden vier vogelkundler am
jadebusen beim tiere beobachten bemerken
sie dass plötzliche hochwasser nicht der
rückweg versperrt da hilft nur noch die
flucht aufs autodach und die rettung per
hubschrauber
und vom herz sturm bei uns jetzt in die
hitze rudi über 40 grad etwas kühler im
stadion natürlich es läuft der vierte
wettkampftag der leichtathletik wm in
doha mit einer fülle an vorentscheiden
entscheidungen die es bislang gab eine
starke vorstellung im speerwerfen zeigte
die deutsche medaillenkandidatin
christin hussong kaum stimmung kaum
thermik aber christin hussong wirft in
der speerwurf qualifikation sehr
respektable 65 meter 29 und die im
ersten versuch
sie steht als zweitbester im finale
bringen wir morgen gar nichts ziemlich
aber noch mal werfen aber ich denke es
ist für das ehrgefühl ganz gut
die zweite deutsche annika marie fuchs
verpasst das finale
gute laune heißt ziel erreicht über 200
meter kommen alle drei deutschen
starterinnen ins halbfinale
lisa marie kahle und tatjana pinto beide
mit persönlichen bestzeiten tatjana
pinto ist mit 22,6 drei sekunden die
schnellste des deutschen trios und es
ist wieder fußball champions league
woche zweiter spieltag bayern münchen
tritt morgen in london bei tottenham
hotspur an das ist der vorjahresfinalist
für den deutschen rekordmeister der
erste internationale härtetest
die white hart lane das teuerste stadion
der welt heimat von tottenham das
zuletzt zwar schwächen offenbart hat vor
dem die bayern denn auch respekt haben
wissen dass dort eine starke mannschaft
ist die letzte champions league finale
war die ich denke in den wichtigen
spielen wenn es drauf ankommen immer da
war
es wird ein stürmer duell tottenham top
torjäger ist harry caine hat fünf
treffer in dieser saison bemerkenswert
aber nur halb so viele die robert
lewandowski mit seinen zehn ligatoren
auch seine treffsicherheit baut bayern
gegen tottenham das gegen piräus nur
unentschieden gespielt hat der druck ist
dort eine muss morgen punkten ja wir
wissen dass wollen natürlich auch morgen
unsere punkte hier mitnehmen oder
unseren punkt minimum bissau fernandez
waren alle beim abschlusstraining dabei
vor dem spiel das zeigen soll ob die
bayern wieder auf dem weg zu
internationalem top niveau sind und hier
geht es gleich weiter wieder live mit
der leichtathletik das schloss danke
rudy vom herbststurm hatten das ja schon
morgen erwartet uns kräftiger regen alle
details gleich von justin kelly der
hinweis noch aus heute-journal 21.45 mit
marietta slomka uns gibt es morgen
wieder vom gesamten heute team der 19
uhr nachrichten danke für ihr interesse
und in allen einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
ein schulamt und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter es wird ziemlich nass in der
kommenden nacht und auch dann morgen
tagsüber regen kommt von westen auf mit
diesem tief hier was sie über
deutschland hinwegziehen sehen ansonsten
kommt an kühle luft dahinter oder ab
mittwoch sinken die temperaturen
deutlich schauen die kommende nacht von
westen her schieben sich die wolken ins
landesinnere und es regnet kräftig dazu
auch gewitter und dann kann es auch noch
verstärkten regen geben im süden dagegen
es ist überwiegend trocken und stern
klar temperaturen dort vier bis sechs
grad am mildesten im westen bei 14 grad
morgen im tagesverlauf also wieder
kräftiger regen der allmählich südwärts
sich bewegt und dabei kann es auch zu
kräftigen schauern kommen und gewittern
im süden dagegen sonnenschein und dort
werte bis 24 grad also nochmal fast ein
sommertag in oberbayern an den küsten
sind es 10 bis 13 grad die nächsten tage
gehen kühl und mit schauern weiter wobei
die temperaturen zwischen 8 und 16 grad
liegen werden damit ein schöner abend